الى اقدم قبيله عايشه على وجه الارض
[موسيقى]
الى درجه انه انا ابغى احس فيهم واعرف كيف
هم عايشين حتى اعزكم الله الجزمه انا
يدخل في رجلك وهذا ويلا وتمشي طول اليوم
قاعدين نمشي ونتبع اثار الحيوانات ونشوف
يارب نلقى لنا فريسه يا رب الله يرزقنا
شيء مره حلو يحسسك بالطبيعه بعدين بعد كم
يوم كذا رجلك تصير انا انسان انا القوي
انا اللي هنا انا اقوى من كل هذه
الحيوانات ههه
اكثر حاجه هم مشهورين فيها طريقه الصيد
لان هم يعني انا اعتبر نفسي طويل الان هم
يوصلون هنا يعني كلهم قصار عشان كذا هم
يسمونهم البوش اللي تخبوا بين الشجيرات
السهم حقهم الصغير ويحطوا في راس السهم سم
هذا جايز سبحان الله مندوده والدوده هذه
عايشه في عش عصفور الدوده هذه سامه هم
يروح ياخذ العش العصفور وياخذ الدوده
ويحطوها في راس السهم وبعدين يلحقوا
الفريسه وكيف يلحق الفريسه يتبعونه اثرها
هذا احلى شيء في الموضوع كله يلحقوه بعدين
لما يلقوا الوقت المناسب يرمي عليها السهم
لما يرمي عليها سهم ياخذ وقت السم في
الحيوان سبحان الله لين خلاص يطيح الحيوان
فممكن تاخذ معاهم الى ايامهم ويلحقوا وراء
الحيوان على حسب حجم الحيوان ويلا وتتبع
وا وراه وتتبعوا وراه يتبع وراه حتى سبحان
الله لما يوصلوا الى الحيوان
يطالع فيه الحيوان كذا عين بعين خلاص
تعبتني وروح يطيح الله سبحان الله ويموت
[موسيقى]
من كثر ما هم مع الطبيعه حتى المسكن اللي
يسكنونه ماخذينه من النمل الابيض سبحان
الله تفاصيل البيت كلها منهم وفيهم من
الطبيعه على طول
وحاجه من الاخير عشان في الحر تعطيك بروده
والبرد دفيك
كانت اول مره اتعلم فيها كيف الطريقه
البدائيه يشبهون فيها نار زي كذا بالعصا
تقعد
وتقطع جلدك كله ويلا ويلا يلا يلا ان شاء
الله يا رب بس عشان تطلع شراره واحده عشان
شراره هذه تشب النار بالنسبه للقوس السهم
طورت مهاراتي فيه الحمد لله كنت اتعلم في
الفتره اللي هم مريحين فيها لا انا قاعد
اتعلم يلا لانه ابغى عصيت معاهم ابغى
احنا كذا ما عليكم اولاد المدينه احنا
برضه اقوياء ما في شيء مستحيل
يا حبيبي
كما